Es geht nicht um Legalität,
es geht um Moral und Verantwortung.
Sie zerstören mein Zuhause und das
Weltklima. Wahnsinn. Vielen Dank.
* Eindringliche Trommelmusik *
(Sprechchor) Brecht die Macht
der Banken und Konzerne!
Brecht die Macht
(Frau) Wessen Zukunft?
- (Frau) Unsere Zukunft.
Klimaprotest am Zürcher Paradeplatz.
Die Aktivisten hier sagen,
dieses riesige Loch
werde auch
von Schweizer Grossbanken finanziert.
Der Braunkohletagebau Garzweiler
des deutschen Konzerns RWE.
Kohle ist der klimaschädlichste
aller Brennstoffe.
Seit den 50er-Jahren
mussten in diesem Gebiet
rund 40'000 Menschen umsiedeln,
weil unter ihrem Boden
Braunkohle liegt.
Es tut richtig weh,
sich das vorzustellen.
Schau dir mal das Haus an.
Die Hälfte steht noch.
Die haben da gelebt.
- Unmenschlich.
Man darf nicht darüber nachdenken,
dass das bei uns in Kuckum
so geplant ist.
Es soll auch so ablaufen.
Das ist ...
- ... einfach nur krank.
Der 28-jährige David Dresen -
vormals Mathelehrer, jetzt Aktivist.
Er und seine Mutter sind auch
von der Umsiedlung betroffen.
Sie verstehen nicht, warum RWE
weitere Dörfer abreissen will.
Deutschland
hat nämlich per Gesetz entschieden,
alle Kohlekraftwerke
bis spätestens 2038 stillzulegen.
(Sprechchor) On est plus chaud,
plus chaud, plus chaud que le climat.
On est plus chaud, plus chaud,
plus chaud que le climat.
Wir haben hier ein TV-Team,
angeblich vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
Willst du die Medien aufbieten?
Antworten.
Aber wie dramatisch
ist die Situation?
Eine Greenpeace-Studie sagt,
Credit Suisse und UBS
hätten Kohle-, Öl- und Gasfirmen
zwischen 2016 und 2019 über Kredite
und Vermittlung am Kapitalmarkt
mit 84 Mrd. $ finanziert.
Stimmt das denn?
Ich beginne meine Recherche
bei Greenpeace.
Grüezi, Frau Bauer.
- Grüezi, Frau Roesle.
Aktivistin Asti Roesle sagt,
die 84 Mrd.
haben mehrere Umweltschutz-
organisationen gemeinsam berechnet,
mithilfe von Finanzdatenbanken.
Es geht wirklich um das Geld,
das unsere Banken direkt
in die fossile Industrie stecken,
indem sie Kredite vergeben.
Sie finanzieren fossile Energie,
die schmutzig ist,
die Flüsse vergiftet,
die die Umwelt zerstört.
Das wollen wir verhindern.
Finanzieren die Schweizer Grossbanken
auch den deutschen Kohlekonzern RWE?
Auch hier verweist Asti Roesle
auf Berechnungen anderer NGO.
Die Zahlen
sind einfach sehr unterschiedlich.
Es gibt Coalexit,
die über die Credit Suisse sagt,
in den Jahren
seit dem Pariser Klimaabkommen
seien 995 Mio.
in RWE investiert worden.
Banktrack
hat die gleiche Analyse gemacht,
die die CS bei 114 Mio. sieht,
also achtmal weniger.
Dasselbe bei der UBS.
Das sind grosse Unterschiede.
Da könnte man kritisch fragen, ob man
den Umweltorganisationen trauen kann.
Es ist weiterhin so,
dass sich Finanzinstitute und Firmen
möglichst wenig in die Karten
schauen lassen wollen.
Darum wehren sich auch viele gegen
die Transparenz zu den Klimarisiken.
Dann kann man das als Umwelt-
organisation gar nicht berechnen.
Doch, das kann man.
Diese Zahlen
stammen aus Businessdatenbanken.
Trotzdem gibt's Unterschiede.
- Das kann auch daran liegen,
wie viele Datenbanken den
Organisationen zur Verfügung stehen.
Also wie viel Geld ihnen
für Recherchen zur Verfügung steht.
Ja. Je vollkommener eine
Datenbank ist, desto teurer ist sie,
und das kann sehr teuer werden
und die Budgets der NGO sprengen.
Folgen wir also der Spur des Geldes.
Die NGO beziehen ihre Daten
von einer Firma in Amsterdam.
Diese Firma ist spezialisiert
auf Finanzrecherchen
mit Bezug zu Umweltfragen.
It's Karin from Swiss TV.
(Mann) Okay.
- Thanks.
Sie heisst Profundo.
Neben NGO sind ihre Kunden Pensions-
kassen, der holländische Staat
und eine Schweizer Privatbank,
die nicht genannt werden will.
Hi, Karin. Nice to meet you.
- Hi, Ward. You too.
Wir arbeiten mit
den Finanzdatenbanken von Bloomberg
und Thomson Reuters Eikon.
Ward Warmerdam
erstellt für uns eine Analyse,
auch zur Finanzierung von RWE.
Er sagt, die UBS habe im Jahr 2016
mit dem deutschen Konzern
Geschäfte gemacht,
die Credit Suisse bis letztes Jahr.
Sie hätten RWE Kredite gewährt und
Gelder am Kapitalmarkt vermittelt.
Die Kredite würden noch laufen.
RWE hat verschiedene Geschäftsfelder.
Neben Kohle
produziert der Konzern auch
Atomkraft, Erdgas und Windenergie.
Nicht alle NGO
machen diese Differenzierung.
Wir fokussieren aber allein auf
die Finanzierung des Kohlesektors.
Wir sehen,
dass die Credit Suisse der Firma RWE
rund 180 Mio. $ fürs Kohlegeschäft
finanziert und vermittelt hat.
Bei der UBS waren es rund 92 Mio.
Damit steht die CS in der Analyse
auf Rang 7 aller Banken,
die mit RWE Geschäfte machen,
die UBS auf Rang 27.
Und wie genau ist diese Analyse?
Es ist eine genaue Schätzung.
Wie viele Prozente des Eisbergs
sehen wir?
Öl, Gas und Kohle
sind kapitalintensive Geschäfte.
Ich denke,
dass wir darum rund 75 % sehen.
Aber es ist sehr schwierig,
das mit Sicherheit zu sagen.
Der deutsche Konzern RWE,
früher Rheinbraun,
ist Europas grösster
Braunkohleproduzent
mit dem europaweit grössten
CO2-Ausstoss.
* Schräge, dunkle Musik *
Als Nächstes soll Keyenberg fallen.
840 Einwohner,
rund 60 % sind schon weg.
* Bellen *
Hallo.- Guten Tag, Frau Bauer.
Kommen Sie rein.
Schatzi, schau mal. Die wollen uns
unbedingt hier raushaben.
Wir sollen dringend
ein Gutachten abgeben.
Das ist natürlich ... Na ja.
Die wollen uns so schnell
wie möglich aus dem Haus raushaben.
Das ist dann Enteignung.
- Ja.
Man darf theoretisch
bis 2023 hier wohnen bleiben.
Die drängeln da richtig drauf.
Da können die uns so viele
Briefe schreiben, wie sie wollen.
Barbara und Walter Oberherr.
Sie arbeitet als Pflegerin,
er ist Beamter.
Sein Grossvater
hat dieses Haus gekauft.
Seit 1935
ist es im Besitz der Familie.
Jetzt sollen sie umziehen.
9 km entfernt
entsteht Neu Keyenberg.
Hat euch RWE
kein Entschädigungsangebot gemacht
und euch im neuen Dorf
keinen Platz zugewiesen?
Doch, man kann mit RWE verhandeln,
und dann kann sich
an diesem neuen Umsiedlungsort
ein Grundstück aussuchen.
Aber diese Grundstücke
sind sehr klein.
Was wir hier haben,
ist unser Himmelreich.
Wie viele Quadratmeter sind das?
- Es ist 4'229 m2.
Das bekommen wir nicht mehr.
* Dissonante, stakkatohafte Musik *
RWE sagt,
der Konzern werde seinen CO2-Ausstoss
bis in zehn Jahren halbieren.
RWE sagt, sie steigen ja aus,
aber das brauche einfach Zeit.
Über 40 % des Stroms hier
stammt noch aus Braunkohle.
Andererseits
hängen 10'000 Arbeitsplätze daran.
Aber wir gehen
in eine kohlefreie Zukunft.
Ich glaube,
die Zeit für Diskussionen darüber,
ob das schnell genug ist,
ist abgelaufen.
Wir wissen, dass wir bis 2030 raus
müssen. Das sagt die Wissenschaft.
Es ist auch Blödsinn,
über Arbeitsplätze zu reden.
Diese Arbeitsplätze
bringen nur Zerstörung.
Die gibt's noch 20 Jahre,
wenn's nach RWE geht.
Dann sind die auch weg.
Moin.
Ein Wachmann von RWE erscheint.
Er sagt,
das Gelände sei Eigentum von RWE.
Hier werde gebaut.
Hier wird zerstört,
hier wird nicht gebaut.
Sie zerstören
das Leben von Menschen.
Das ist keine Baustelle,
sondern Vernichtung.
Was denken Sie darüber?
Ernsthaft, von Mensch zu Mensch.
Der Wachmann fordert uns auf,
das Gelände zu verlassen.
Dabei treffen wir
auf weitere Sicherheitsleute.
Die Stimmung eskaliert.
Sie vernichten mein Zuhause
und ich habe keine Rechte mehr.
Demokratie heisst nicht,
dass irgendein Idiot bestimmt.
Demokratie heisst: Grundrechte
von Minderheiten gelten auch.
Sie seien keine Raubritter,
sagen die Leute von RWE.
Ihr Handeln sei legal.
Es geht nicht um Legalität,
es geht um Moral und Verantwortung.
Ist etwas Legales
per se etwas Gutes?
Deswegen müssen wir
darüber nachdenken,
ob es unsere Moral sein kann,
Dörfer zu vernichten
und Menschen ihre Heimat zu rauben.
Das ist eine moralische Frage,
keine gesetzliche.
* Gedrückte,
etwas verzerrte Gitarrenklänge *
(Sprechchor) Wir sind hier, wir sind
laut, weil man uns die Zukunft klaut.
Wir sind hier, wir sind laut,
weil man uns die Zukunft klaut.
When do you want it?
- (Alle) Now!
Grüezi. Sie arbeiten
für die Credit Suisse.
Entschuldigung,
darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Was halten Sie von dieser Aktion
der Klimaaktivisten?
Sie arbeiten für die Credit Suisse.
- Nein, für die UBS.
Aber glauben Sie,
Sie arbeiten für eine Klimasünderin?
Das würde ich nicht sagen.
Wir bemühen uns sehr
um sustainable investments.
Als Mitarbeiterin
kann ich leider ...
Sie dürfen nichts sagen, aber sind
Sie über die Erderwärmung besorgt?
Ja, die macht mir Sorgen.
Darum habe ich den Zettel genommen.
(Sprechchor) Résistance!
Diese Durchsage erfolgt per Megafon,
damit alle sie hören:
Die Polizei wird den Eingang
in 5 Min. frei machen.
Die Grossbanken
machen keine Aussagen zu Firmen,
denen sie Kredite gewähren.
Das sei Geschäftsgeheimnis.
UBS und CS betonen aber,
sie würden keine neuen
Kohlekraftwerke mehr finanzieren
und hätten
nachhaltige Anlagestrategien.
Die UBS sagt für ein Interview erst
zu, dann wieder ab. Sie schreibt:
Gemeint sind v.a. Kredite
an Kohle-, Öl und Gasfirmen.
Die 1,9 Mrd. sind der Betrag,
den die Firmen noch nicht
an die Bank zurückgezahlt haben.
Die Profundo-Analyse aber
basiert darauf,
wie viel Kredit die UBS
den Firmen gesamthaft gegeben hat.
Die Bank kommuniziert das nicht.
Die Credit Suisse
gewährt ein Interview
mit ihrem Beauftragten
für Nachhaltigkeit.
Ich hätte 5 Min. Zeit,
heisst es zunächst.
Es gelingt mir,
10 Min. mehr auszuhandeln.
Die Auflage kommt vom Pressesprecher.
Seit dem Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen
hat die Credit Suisse den Kohleabbau
laut Finanzdatenbanken
mit rund 2 Mrd. $
durch Kredite und Vermittlungen
am Kapitalmarkt finanziert.
Im internationalen Vergleich
liegt die Bank damit
auf dem fünften Rang.
Diese Zahl ist
in den letzten Jahren rückläufig.
Wir haben im Juli 2020
eine Strategie bekannt gegeben,
laut der wir
Kreditvergaben an Firmen
mit mehr als 25 % Umsatz
aus dem Abbau von Kraftwerkskohle
oder der Herstellung von Strom
aus Kohle einstellen werden.
Klimawissenschaftler sagen,
das reiche nicht.
Wir sollten laut dem
Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen
bis 2030 ganz
aus der Kohle ausgestiegen sein.
Mitbewerber wie die Royal Bank
of Scotland oder die Groupe Mutuel
finanzieren ab 2030
gar keine Kohle mehr.
Wieso tut die Credit Suisse
da nicht mehr?
Ich persönlich glaube,
dass wir in Zukunft weiter gehen
und die Angleichung an die
Pariser Ziele weitertreiben werden.
Also ab 2030 keine Kohlenfinanzierung
mehr durch die Credit Suisse?
Das kann ich noch nicht sagen, aber
es geht definitiv in diese Richtung.
Es geht auch um den Ruf der Bank.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Im rheinischen Revier bin ich
bei Familie Dresen eingeladen.
Auch ihr Dorf Kuckum
steht auf der Abrissliste von RWE.
(Frau) Ihr seid super.
Klasse. Ja, fein.
Auch Familie Dresen besitzt viel
Land, das sie nicht aufgeben will.
Maritas Sohn
ist wieder nach Hause gezogen.
Ich habe mein gesamtes vorheriges
Leben aufgegeben, um das zu tun.
Wir leben in einer Welt, in der das
leider notwendig geworden ist.
Weder die Landesregierung NRW
noch die Bundesregierung
sind bisher auch nur einen Schritt
auf uns zugegangen.
Wie ist das für Sie?
- Grauenhaft.
Politisch haben wir de facto
noch nichts erreicht.
Ich habe so viel Energie
reingesteckt
und bekomme als Rückmeldung
von den zuständigen Stellen nur,
dass wir ihnen scheissegal sind.
Dieses Gefühl der Machtlosigkeit
hatte ich davor nicht.
Keyenberg ist als Nächstes dran.
In drei Jahren soll es abgerissen
werden. Viele sind schon weg.
Ja, der Metzger
hat sein Geschäft auch geschlossen,
weil ja die Kunden
rundherum wegbrechen.
Hallo, Hedwig. Komm zu uns.
Wir sind froh, noch
gut gelaunte Keyenberger zu treffen.
Ich komme gerade aus der Kirche.
Ich habe gekündigt.
- Oh.
Ja.
Es muss sein, es geht nicht anders.
Hedwig Drabik
ist seit fast 20 Jahren
die Sigristin
von Keyenbergs Kirche.
Es ist wirklich schrecklich,
weil ich das
nur aus der Zeitung erfahren habe.
Aus der Zeitung?
Aus der Zeitung habe ich erfahren,
dass die Kirche schon verkauft ist.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Niemand hat vorher
mit dir darüber gesprochen?- Nein.
Das ist eine grobe Unverschämtheit.
Ja, so ist es.
Kirche und Haus wurden verkauft. Das
habe ich aus der Zeitung erfahren.
Alles an RWE?
- An RWE verkauft, ja.
Wollte der Pfarrer
das nicht öffentlich machen?
Keine Ahnung. Ich denke nicht.
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Auch die Kirche, ein Bau im
neugotischen Stil, wird abgerissen.
Zwar gilt sie
als schützenswertes Denkmal,
laut deutschem Gesetz
geht die Energieversorgung aber vor.
Mal sehen, wie alles wird.
Hältst du eben Emma fest?
- Ja, ja.
Morgen, Wolfgang.
- Morgen, Barbara.
Wie geht's?
- Ja, nichts Neues.
Gibst du mir so ein Körnerbrot?
Mit vielen Körnern.
- Okay. Was kriegst du dafür?
3 Euro.
Wie sieht das denn bei dir aus?
- Eher schlecht.
Schlecht?
- Ja, weisst du doch.
Und?
- Nichts Neues.
Ich hab mit denen
noch nicht verhandelt.
Lohnt sich das für dich
am neuen Ort?
Was heisst "lohnt sich das"?
Wir werden keine Perspektive haben.
Die Lage ist beschissen.
Drei Discounter
direkt in der Nachbarschaft -
das kannst du knicken.
Da werden wir wahrscheinlich
in der Beziehung nicht tätig werden.
Ein neuer Betrieb kostet,
sagen wir mal,
30-40 % mehr
als ein älterer Betrieb -
vielleicht noch mehr.
Die sind nicht bereit,
das zu bezahlen.
RWE entschädigt das nicht?
- Nein, also ...
Wir bekommen ja nur
den aktuellen Wert.
Ja.
Wir sollten da was tun.
Wir wollen ja nicht, dass Greta
noch mal vor der Kamera weint.
* Gedrückte, verzerrte Musik *
Zurück zum Grubenrand
und zu jenem Dorf,
das in den letzten Jahren
der Braunkohle weichen musste.
Immerath.
David Dresen und seine Mutter
besuchen die letzte Bewohnerin
des Geisterdorfs.
Hallihallo.
- (Lachend) Hi.
Hallo.
Mindestens zwölf Jahre
haben wir uns nicht gesehen.
Das kann gut sein.
Eine Bäuerin, die noch keinen Ersatz
für ihren grossen Hof gefunden hat
und immer noch mit RWE verhandelt.
Ich dachte:
"Krass, dass ihr hier noch lebt."
Heftig, in der Umgebung.
- Ja, heftig.
Aber wenn man hier drin ist, kann
man sich das Gefühl aufbauen:
"Wir sind hier ..."
Überall sind Bäume und Mauern -
wie das Paradies in der Hölle.
Wirklich abgeschottet.
- Ja.
Da kriegst du echt nichts mit.
- Nein, wirklich nicht.
Das hier ist die Freiheitsstrasse.
Auweia.
Ich berichte über unsere Recherche,
wie viel Geld RWE für den Kohlesektor
seit 2016 erhalten hat.
Auf den ersten beiden Rängen
stehen zwei amerikanische Banken.
Die Credit Suisse liegt auf Rang 7.
Was sagt ihr dazu?
Interessant. Absolut interessant
und schockierend, ganz klar.
V.a. ist da die ganze Welt dabei.
- Ja.
Es ist erschreckend,
dass es immer nur ums Geld geht.
Es geht nicht um die Menschen.
Ich glaube, denen ist gar nicht
bewusst, was sie finanzieren
und welche Auswirkungen das
auf die Menschen hier hat.
Die Credit Suisse gibt 180 Mio.
ans Braunkohlegeschäft der RWE.
Diese Bank ist mit daran schuld,
dass wir unser Zuhause verlieren
und das Klima vernichtet wird.
Kredite für schlimme Unternehmen
sind nicht besser,
als selbst
ein schlimmes Unternehmen zu sein.
Was sagen Sie den Bewohnern,
die sagen,
die CS mache sich mitschuldig daran,
dass sie umziehen müssen?
Das ist bedauerlich. Es ist Teil
des Prozesses dieser Transformation.
Die Firma,
die Sie ansprechen, ist dabei,
ihre Kapazität in der Erzeugung
von erneuerbarer Energie zu erhöhen.
Aber wie gesagt,
der Strom aus der Steckdose
kommt zum kleinsten Teil
aus Wind- und Solarenergie.
Der Übergang wird dauern,
und er wird Kapital benötigen.
(Sprechchor) Roger Federer,
du weisst genau,
deine Freunde bei der CS
haben's Klima versaut.
Roger Federer, du weisst genau ...
Gehen Sie bitte
hinter die Absperrung.
64 Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten
wurden verhaftet.
Die meisten erhielten
einen Strafbefehl wegen Nötigung,
einige auch wegen Hausfriedensbruchs.
* Lautes Stimmengewirr *
Aua.
Es geht aber nicht nur ums Klima,
sondern auch ums Geschäftsrisiko.
Der Finanzplatz
riskiert nämlich Verluste,
wenn er weiterhin
in Kohle, Öl und Gas investiert.
Wie gross die Klimarisiken sind,
berechnet die Firma Carbon Delta
in Zürich.
This is emission sector level 2.
Geschäftsführer Oliver Marchand,
ein Informatiker.
Der Kohlesektor
trägt das grösste Risiko.
In unserem Modell
ist RWE eine eher riskante Firma.
Energieintensive Stromerzeuger
im EU-Raum
müssen für
ihren CO2-Ausstoss bezahlen.
In den letzten Jahren
ist der Preis dafür stark gestiegen.
Carbon Delta
hat ein hypothetisches Modell
für die Zukunft von RWE berechnet,
unter der Annahme, dass der CO2-Preis
weiterhin stark steigt.
Im Modell liegt der CO2-Ausstoss
von RWE bei aktuell 60 Mio. t.
Unter den wichtigen Klimaszenarien -
Paris Agreement, 2 °C und 1,5 °C -
müsste das sogar
auf unter 20 sinken,
also auf weniger als ein Drittel.
Nach unseren Abschätzungen
würde das heissen,
dass nach all diesen Klimaszenarien
RWE gar keine Gewinne mehr
erzeugen könnte
und das Unternehmen
damit eigentlich wertlos ist.
RWE sagt,
das Thema sei viel zu komplex,
um auf der Basis von Annahmen
Aussagen für die Zukunft zu treffen.
Für Kohlestrom werde auch 2030 noch
eine Nachfrage bestehen.
Niemand könne den Preis vorhersagen.
Patrick Uelfeti
verwaltet die Vermögen
der grössten Pensionskasse, Publica.
Er ist Kunde von Carbon Delta.
Guten Tag, Herr Marchand.
- Grüezi, Herr Uelfeti.
Wie geht's Ihnen?
- Ja, gut, und Ihnen?
Pensionskassen gehören zu den ersten,
die auf Klimarisiken reagieren.
Sie legen die Vermögen
ihrer Versicherten langfristig an.
Sie sind ja
die grösste Pensionskasse.
Kam da Druck von Versicherten
oder aus der Politik,
Sie müssten
mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen?
Ja, wir spüren schon einen gewissen
Druck und dass Interesse besteht.
Wir glauben, dass das ein Faktor
in unserem Portfolio ist,
den wir beobachten müssen.
Das Factsheet von Universum.
Die Publica
reduziert ihre Investitionen
in Firmen mit hohem CO2-Ausstoss
um bis zu 70 %,
wenn die Firmen keinen glaubwürdigen
Plan für die CO2-Reduktion haben.
Im Gegenzug
wird in Firmen investiert,
die Technologien
für weniger CO2-Ausstoss entwickeln
und dafür Patente angemeldet haben.
Hier z.B. ein Autobauer, Renault.
Wir sehen,
Renault hat etwa 10'000 Patente.
Das ist typisch,
weil ein Auto viele Teile hat.
Ungefähr ein Viertel davon
sind Patente,
die mit kohlenstoffarmen
Technologien zu tun haben.
In diesem Fall kann man sagen,
dass sie nicht nur darüber reden,
sondern auch
Patente mit Potenzial einreichen.
Ja.
Könnten Credit Suisse und UBS
wie Publica
weniger Geld
in Kohle, Öl und Gas investieren?
Das wäre eine super Sache.
Ich würde das
jedem Finanzinstitut empfehlen.
Ich persönlich ...
- 50 % weniger in Kohle, Öl und Gas?
Bestimmt.
Wie wirkt sich das
auf die Rendite aus?
Das kann niemand vorhersagen,
aber unsere Simulationen zeigen,
dass das
eine Überrendite erzeugen würde.
Also mehr, als man heute erzielt?
- Richtig.
* Dunkle Klavierklänge *
Die Schweizer Banken
sind auch bei Öl und Gas im Geschäft.
Rund 45 Mrd. $
hat die Credit Suisse seit 2016
Öl- und Gasfirmen als Kredit gewährt
und am Kapitalmarkt vermittelt -
fast doppelt so viel wie die UBS,
lautet die Analyse von Profundo.
Im Bereich fossile Energien
sind diese Firmen
bei der Credit Suisse seit 2016
in den oberen Rängen:
Diamondback Energy,
Parsley Energy und EP Energy.
Sie alle bohren
im amerikanischen Texas nach Öl.
Jedes Feld ist ein Bohrplatz.
Wie Pilze sind sie in den letzten
zehn Jahren aus dem Boden geschossen.
(Trump) Hier in Texas haben wir
die Zahl der Bohrtürme verdoppelt,
und die Rohölproduktion
hat ein Rekordhoch erreicht.
Die USA ist weltweit die Nummer 1
in der Öl- und Gasproduktion.
Wir haben uns aus dem einseitigen
Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen
zurückgezogen.
Dieses Abkommen ist gut für Paris,
aber nicht gut für uns.
Wir sind auf der sog. Todesautobahn.
Sie heisst so,
weil es während des Frackingbooms
viele Verkehrsunfälle gab.
Ist das der neue Goldrausch?
Das ist der neue Goldrausch.
Früher war sie
bei einer Ölfirma angestellt,
heute arbeitet Sharon Wilson
für eine Umweltschutzorganisation.
Anfang Jahr
fahren wir durch das Permian Basin,
ein riesiges Öl- und Gasfeld.
Es erstreckt sich vom Westen
von Texas bis nach New Mexico.
Das Gebiet ist fünfmal so gross
wie die Schweiz.
Fracking ist umstritten.
Erdöl und Erdgas liegen Hunderte
Meter tief im Schiefergestein.
Um sie zu fördern,
werden einige Millionen Liter Wasser
mit Sand und Chemikalien versetzt und
unter Hochdruck in die Erde gepresst.
Durch den Druck
entstehen Risse im Schiefer,
sodass Öl und Gas frei werden.
In Texas dreht sich alles ums Öl.
Auf dem Markt
hat Gas fast keinen Wert.
Darum, und weil es
nicht genug Pipelines gibt,
wird es oft abgebrannt.
Die Flamme ist CO2,
also klimaschädliches Treibhausgas.
Laut der Energieberatungsfirma
Rystad Energy
wurde letztes Jahr im Permian Basin
so viel Gas abgefackelt,
dass die rund 7 Mio. Haushalte
in Texas
damit hätten geheizt werden können.
Wir fahren zu einer Bohrstelle
von Diamondback Energy.
Sie heisst Misbehaving.
Schauen wir also,
wie sie sich benimmt.
Laut Profundo-Analyse
hat die CS seit 2016
rund 2,6 Mrd. $ für Diamondback
finanziert und vermittelt.
In den Tanks lagere das gefrackte
Öl und Gas, sagt Sharon.
Sie ist mit einer
speziellen Kamera unterwegs.
Das ist eine Infrarotkamera.
Sie macht die unsichtbaren Gas-
emissionen dieser Anlagen sichtbar.
Schauen wir mal,
was aus dem Ventil dort kommt.
Es ist viel.
Let me focus.
Wow, yeah.
Es sind Kohlenwasserstoffe,
die die Gesundheit schädigen -
v.a. Methan.
Methan ist
ein sehr starkes Treibhausgas.
Es beschleunigt den Klimawandel.
Methangas
ist quasi der böse Zwilling von CO2.
Sein Treibhauseffekt
ist viel stärker.
Für Methan gibt es in Texas
keine direkten Grenzwerte.
Die Behörden messen nicht,
wie viel Gas in die Luft entweicht.
Niemand misst das.
Die Emissionswerte, die
die Behörde hat, sind Schätzungen.
Sie werden
von den Ölfirmen gemeldet.
Das ist, als würde ich
die Polizei anrufen und sagen,
dass ich gestern zu schnell gefahren
bin und gebüsst werden will.
Das wird nie passieren.
Der Kriminelle ist der Sheriff.
Kommt dazu, dass Ölfirmen
den Methanausstoss
und das Volumen
des abgefackelten Gases
bisher
mit einer einzigen Zahl melden.
Bei Diamondback ist sie
im Vergleich zu anderen Firmen
überdurchschnittlich hoch.
Die Firma
beantwortet meine Fragen dazu nicht.
Eine neue Studie,
publiziert in "Nature", zeigt:
Die Förderung
von fossilen Energieträgern
trägt weit mehr
zum weltweiten Methanausstoss bei
als bisher angenommen -
zwischen 25 und 38 %.
Fracking heizt das Klima auf
und schädigt die Umwelt.
Aber nicht nur das.
There's a deer right there.
"Where do I run? Where do I run?"
He's still there.
- I see him.
Letztes Jahr
sind Sue Franklin und ihr Mann
aus der Frackingzone weggezogen,
mit ihrem Haus.
Davor aber hat das Ehepaar
drei Jahre lang
inmitten der Bohrtürme
und Tanks gelebt.
Thank you.
- You betcha.
Eines Nachts erwachte ich
und roch Gas.
Es roch nach faulen Eiern.
Ich lag im Bett und fragte mich:
"Was zur Hölle passiert mit mir?"
Danach bekam ich Nasenbluten.
Ich ging zu meinem Arzt und sagte:
"Ich weiss nicht,
wie sich Asthma anfühlt,
aber manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
nicht mehr atmen zu können."
Asthmatiker erleiden gemäss
Wissenschaftlern mehr Anfälle,
wenn sie in der Nähe
von Frackingorten leben.
Hier haben wir gelebt.
Ich habe die Ranch 2004 gekauft.
Wo genau stand sie?
Auf der anderen Seite des Zauns.
Dann haben sie
Bohrstellen errichtet.
Dort hinten sind drei.
* Er hustet. *
Dann begannen sie,
im Westen zu bohren.
* Husten *
Ich kann diese schlechte Luft
nicht atmen.
Als sie frackten, bebte unser Haus.
Es gibt keine Worte, um die Gier
dieses Landes zu beschreiben.
Es ist eine Schande.
Yeah, it's terrible.
Schau dir das an.
Die Fackel brennt nicht.
Sie sollte das Methan abbrennen.
Stattdessen ist das
ein riesiges Entlüftungsrohr.
Das Methan entweicht einfach.
Ist das legal?
- Nein.
Methan sollte nicht
in die Luft entweichen.
Es ist so
noch viel schädlicher fürs Klima,
als wenn es abgebrannt würde.
Die Behörden
erteilen aber Ausnahmebewilligungen.
Auch diese Anlage
gehört Diamondback Energy.
Laut Analyse von Profundo war die UBS
bis letztes Jahr mit ihr im Geschäft,
die CS auch dieses Jahr.
Die Banken haben spezielle Weisungen
für Umweltrisiken.
I guess this guy is going
to come ask us about it. Hey.
Ich habe gehört,
dass Sie Fragen zur Fackel haben?
Ja, sie brennt
seit einiger Zeit nicht mehr.
Dieses Wochenende brannte sie,
aber wir haben
ein paar Probleme damit.
Wir haben eine Liste
mit Fackeln, die nicht brennen.
Wir sind daran, sie zu reparieren.
- Was ist denn das Problem?
Manchmal werden sie heiss
und schmelzen.
Und dann entlasst ihr das Methan bis
zur Reparatur einfach in die Luft?
Das kann leider manchmal passieren.
Eigentlich müsste das Gas
in Pipelines abtransportiert werden,
aber deren Bau ist teuer.
Darum wird es oft abgebrannt.
Die Behörden erteilen dafür praktisch
immer Ausnahmebewilligungen -
z.B. für Diamondback letztes Jahr.
Die Behörde schreibt:
Der Bau einer Pipeline ist teuer,
darum entlassen sie das Gas
einfach in die Luft.
D.h., die Wirtschaft
ist wichtiger als die Umwelt?
In Texas ist das keine Schlagzeile.
Die Wirtschaft war schon immer
wichtiger als die Umwelt.
* Dumpfe, elektronische Musik *
* Lautes Rauschen *
Was ist jetzt los?
Keine Ahnung. Es klingt,
als ob Gas austreten würde.
Wie kommt das bei Ihnen an,
wenn die Credit Suisse schreibt,
die Bank wolle Öl und Gas
auf verantwortliche Weise fördern,
sodass die Umwelt
und das Klima geschützt werden?
Das ist scheisse!
Darf man das
am Schweizer Fernsehen sagen?
Es ist scheisse!
Es ist verantwortungslos,
weiter Öl und Gas zu produzieren.
Einige Bohrtürme
wurden erst vor Kurzem gebaut.
Es geht in die falsche Richtung.
Sie machen da mit?
Ja, die Freisetzung von Methan
ist ein Problem.
Das ist auch der Industrie bewusst.
Sie haben selbst gesagt, wie viel
Energie man daraus gewinnen könnte,
welche sinnvolle Verwendung
das haben könnte.
Das widerspricht ja diametral
den CS-Richtlinien.
Die CS schaut genau, wie Firmen
das Abfackeln überschüssigen Gases
zu minimieren versuchen.
Wir haben ein Beispiel einer Firma,
die Sie finanzieren,
die das einfach in die Luft entlässt.
Da haben sich eigentlich nur
Umweltschutzleute angeschaut,
was da in die Luft entlassen wird.
Und wenn eine Bank
sehr viel Geld gibt,
finanziert sie diese Emissionen mit.
Ich habe gesagt,
die Branche hat das Problem erkannt.
Das führt auch zu Akzeptanz-
schwierigkeiten dieser Industrie.
Die Frackingindustrie
ist nicht nur umweltpolitisch heikel,
sondern auch finanziell.
Fracking ist ein Geschäft auf Pump.
Das Bohren ist teuer
und die Ölquellen
versiegen nach einigen Jahren.
Fällt der Ölpreis, werden Schulden
mit neuen Schulden bezahlt,
weil die Quellen
nicht genug Cash einbringen.
(Mann) This is Houston Newsmakers
with Khambrel Marshall.
Der schlimmste Fall ist eingetreten.
Der Preis für ein Barrel Öl
ist unter null gefallen.
Das ist noch nie passiert.
Der Ölpreis bringt uns um.
Die finanzielle Einbusse
könnte über 500'000 Jobs kosten.
Über 30 US-Öl- und Gasfirmen
sind seit Beginn der Pandemie
Konkurs gegangen.
Das bedeutet rund 30 Mrd. $ Verlust
für Banken und Investoren.
Das hilft uns dann wieder dabei,
die Geschäftspolitik
und den Risikoappetit zu justieren.
Bei der CS
sind 7,5 Mrd. $ an Krediten
im Öl- und Gasgeschäft ausstehend,
fast 50 % non investment grade,
d.h. riskant mit einem grösseren
Ausfallrisiko als investment grade.
Das ist eineinhalbmal so viel
wie der Jahresgewinn.
Das klingt recht gefährlich.
Das ist Teil des Risikomanagements.
Ich denke, wir haben
die Ausfallrisiken unter Kontrolle,
aber wir sind sehr eng dran
und verfolgen das.
Bei meinen Recherchen in Texas
fällt mir noch eine andere Firma auf:
Energy Transfer, eine Pipelinefirma.
Von all ihren Geschäften
mit fossilen Energieträgern
hat die CS dieser Firma
am zweitmeisten Mittel beschafft:
rund 2,5 Mrd. $
seit dem Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen.
Das ist fast zehnmal mehr
als die UBS,
die laut Profundo rund 265 Mio.
für Energy Transfer beschafft hat.
Den Namen Energy Transfer
hört man nicht zum ersten Mal.
Credit Suisse geriet 2017
in die Kritik wegen einer Ölpipeline,
die durch das Land
von Indigenen führt.
Die Bank sagte damals, sie finanziere
die Pipeline nicht direkt,
vergebe aber Kredite
an involvierte Firmen.
(Frau) Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be arriving ...
Ich reise in den Staat Pennsylvania -
mit dem Flugzeug,
das natürlich auch CO2 verbraucht,
aber anders
lässt sich in nützlicher Frist
nicht über dieses Thema berichten.
Auch in Pennsylvania wird gefrackt.
Im Vergleich zu Texas
gibt es hier viel mehr Gas als Öl.
Darum werden hier
viele Pipelines gebaut,
auch von Energy Transfer.
Hinter jedem Haus
auf der linken Seite der Ivy Lane
ist die Pipeline
von Energy Transfer.
Karen Gdula lebt neben einer Pipeline
Sie erzählt mir ihre Geschichte.
Ich lebe in dem Haus,
in dem ich aufgewachsen bin.
Als Kind hatte ich
einen wiederkehrenden Albtraum:
Die Wälder
hinter unserem Haus brannten.
Am 10. September 2018
wachte ich auf,
und die Wälder brannten.
Der Albtraum aus meiner Kindheit
war plötzlich real.
(Mann) Ein gigantischer Feuerball
erleuchtete den Nachthimmel.
Das Inferno zerstörte mehrere Häuser
in Beaver County.
Die Explosion leuchtete orange.
Sie war kilometerweit sichtbar.
Das möchte ich nie mehr erleben.
Ob die Schweizer Grossbanken
diese Pipeline direkt finanzierten,
wissen wir nicht.
Die Profundo-Analyse zeigt aber,
dass die UBS
Energy Transfer
letztmals 2017 einen Kredit gewährte,
die CS auch noch 2018 und 2019.
Schön, dich zu sehen, Chuck.
- Yes, nice seeing you.
Chuck ist Karens Nachbar.
Hi, Chuck.
- Hi, Karin. Nice to meet you.
Gehen wir hier entlang. Hier können
wir die Explosionsstelle gut sehen.
Over here.
So this is it?
Die Nachbarschaft hat die Explosion
nur mit Glück überlebt.
Karen zeigt mir den Hang,
an dem die Pipeline gebaut wurde.
Direkt unterhalb ihrer Häuser.
Revolution heisst die Pipeline.
Teilte Energy Transfer euch mit,
dass sie eine Pipeline bauten,
und präsentierten sie euch
einen Notfallplan?
Nein, sie informierten nicht einmal
unsere lokalen Behörden.
Pipeline-Firmen
müssen niemanden informieren,
wenn sie eine Pipeline
in Betrieb nehmen.
Wir wussten nichts davon.
Darum war die Explosion
ein doppelter Schock für uns.
It was enough
to shake off the deepest sleep.
Mein Mann und ich schliefen,
als wir eine Erschütterung
wie von einem grossen Truck spürten.
Mein Mann hörte das Dröhnen
und rannte zum Fenster.
Er wusste sofort,
dass es die Pipeline war.
Die Flamme schoss 45 m in die Höhe.
Man sah sie
aus kilometerweiter Entfernung.
(Frau) Autofahrer
trauten ihren Augen nicht:
helllichter Tag vor Sonnenaufgang.
Ich sagte zu ihm: "Zieh dich an
und hol deine Medikamente."
"Wir evakuieren."
Die Angst war uns allen
ins Gesicht geschrieben.
Wir waren alle im Überlebensmodus.
Ein Erdrutsch hatte die Pipeline
zerrissen und zur Explosion gebracht.
Energy Transfer
hatte den Hang zu wenig stabilisiert.
Die Firma wusste laut
internen Papieren schon seit Jahren,
dass der Hang rutschgefährdet war.
Energy Transfer
will das nicht kommentieren.
Hey, Don, come on in.
- How are you doing?
Good to see you.
- Good to see you too.
Please come on in and join us.
Have a seat.
Aktuelles Gesprächsthema der Nachbarn
ist die Busse von 30 Mio. $,
die die Firma bezahlen muss.
... years ago outside of Pittsburgh.
Macht euch das wütend?
Nicht wirklich.
Sie ärgert sich schon genug.
Was würden Sie denn sagen?
Wurde mit Ihren Leben gespielt?
Ich glaube, die Firma versuchte es,
aber der Schuss
ging nach hinten los.
Energy Transfer
gehört zu den US-Pipeline-Firmen,
die die höchsten Bussen
für Umweltprobleme zahlen müssen -
Dutzende Millionen.
Es laufen auch strafrechtliche
Untersuchungen gegen die Firma.
Was kann ich schon machen? Nichts.
Grosse Konzerne
hören nicht auf eine Stimme
oder auf mehrere Stimmen.
Es ist sehr frustrierend.
Ich bin hier, weil auch Banken
die Pipelines finanzieren.
Credit Suisse hat Energy Transfer
in den letzten vier Jahren
Kredite von über 1,7 Mrd. $ gewährt,
laut Finanzdatenbanken.
Seht ihr eine Verantwortung?
- Ich glaube, die Bank hat versagt.
Credit Suisse?
- Yes.
Sie hat die falsche Firma gewählt.
Eine Bank
sollte eine Firma untersuchen,
bevor sie Kredite vergibt,
wie sie es auch
bei uns Bankkunden tut.
Sie sollte Verstösse
und Untersuchungen gegen eine Firma
unter die Lupe nehmen
und sich fragen, was da los ist.
Wenn man sich
solche Verstösse anschaut ...
Wichtig ist:
ein grosser Teil davon
findet quasi
auf dem Areal der Firma statt -
z.B. eine Tankstelle, wo ab und zu
Diesel oder Benzin ausfliesst.
Die Regulierung in den USA
sieht vor,
dass selbst kleinste Mengen
von Ausfluss gemeldet werden müssen.
Vor zwei Jahren
ist eine Pipeline explodiert.
Da waren Menschen in Gefahr.
Wieso ist die CS
nie aus dieser Firma ausgestiegen?
Zumal auch Klimaschützer sagen,
wenn man die Pariser Klimaschutzziele
ernst nehme,
gehe es nicht,
weitere Infrastruktur zu bauen,
die wieder 50 Jahre
für fossile Energieträger lebt.
Wieso steigt man da nicht aus?
Wie gesagt, wir machen uns
ständig Gedanken darüber,
was noch geht und was nicht.
Können Sie den Zuschauern
hier und jetzt etwas versprechen?
Nein, ich kann jetzt
nichts versprechen.
* Popsong: "Money's Too Tight"
von Simply Red *
# We're talking about money, money.
# We're talking
about the dollar bill.
Seit dem Protest am Paradeplatz
ist ein Jahr vergangen.
Diese Affen
stehen symbolisch für die Politik,
für Bundesrat und Parlament,
die wegschauen wollen.
Die freiwilligen Massnahmen der
Finanzinstitute reichen nicht aus.
Es ist ganz klar:
Wir brauchen jetzt
regulative Massnahmen.
Wir brauchen das Parlament,
den Bundesrat und die Behörden.
Was sagen die Aktivisten
zum Versprechen der CS,
über die nächsten zehn Jahre
300 Mrd. an nachhaltiger Finanzierung
bereitzustellen?
Löblich, aber nicht genug,
solange die Bank noch
Kohle, Öl und Gas finanziere.
Guten Morgen.
Wir sind heute hier, um
unsere Volksbeschwerde einzureichen.
Peter, wie viele haben
bis gestern Abend unterzeichnet?
23'768 Personen.
Ich sehe, es passiert etwas.
Ein grosser Teil
der Gesellschaft will,
dass sich etwas bewegt.
Es gibt so viele Gruppen.
Es ist etwas in Bewegung.
# Now what are we all to do
when money's got a hold on you?
Und was findet ihr?
Wie schnell sollen Banken, Versicherungen und Pensionskassen
aus Kohle, Öl und Gas aussteigen?
Bewegt sich da was, wie die Banken sagen, oder müsste der Ausstieg
viel schneller passieren?
Oder sollte er gar vom Staat reglementiert werden, wie Greenpeace fordert?
Schreibt mir eure Meinungen und offene Fragen in die Kommentare.